[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN VEIZADES: Good
morning, everyone.
Thank you for sticking around
through the last day of Google
Next.
And today we're
going to be talking
about how you can take
your enterprise network
and extend it out
into the Cloud,
various ways of doing that,
talking about reliability
of those mechanisms, and
talking about many use cases
on how you do that.
So let's start off.
So you've all seen this picture
or a picture much like it.
And this is the Google
backbone, and the network
that you can connect to.
So one of the things we
like to emphasize here
is that when you
make connections
to your VPC in Cloud,
you really are connecting
to this infrastructure.
So if you think about
the kind of connections
we're going to be talking about
today, which are connections
from your enterprise
into cloud, it's also
connections into this
backbone, and it's a way
to leverage that backbone.
So there's a number of ways
you can connect to Google.
I'm going to talk
briefly about two methods
that I'm not going to talk in
the rest of the deck about.
One of them is direct and the
other one is carrier peering.
For customers that need to
connect to the Google public
infrastructure-- and what
I mean by the Google public
infrastructure, that's our ASN
15169 and all of the public
Google services--
that's Search, that's G
Suite, that's YouTube,
and all the rest of it.
The way you can connect to us
is either using direct peering
or carrier peering.
Direct peering is
where you meet us
in one of our peering locations,
and there are roughly about 100
all over the world.
And you place a router there
and you peer with us using BGP.
You need to meet our
peering requirements.
And for many customers,
that's very difficult.
So we have another product
called carrier peering,
and that's when you work with
one of our service provider
partners-- and there's a
list on our website of them--
and allow them to peer
on your behalf with us.
A lot of customers use this.
Some use it for G Suite
connectivity, others
because they want real low
latency and fast access
to YouTube.
I'm kidding.
The other methods
for connecting are
VPN, which we're going to
talk about today, which
is a way of using
a cryptographically
secure method of connecting
over the internet to GCP
networks, your VPC and GCP.
And then finally, dedicated
and partner interconnect.
Dedicated and
partner interconnect
very much closely match
the direct peering
and carrier pairing solutions.
With dedicated interconnect,
you meet us in one of our POPs.
And with partner
interconnect, you
meet with one of our carriers,
which meets in one of our POPs.
And I'll go into details
about both of those.
So which one do I use?
This is a flowchart
that kind of tries
to help you make
those decisions.
By the way, a similar version
of this flowchart is available
on the
cloud.google.com/interconnect
site.
So for instance, if
you're using G Suite,
it sort of moves you to direct
peering or carrier peering.
If you don't need
a 10 gig pipe, it
tells you maybe you want to
use partnered interconnect
versus dedicated interconnect.
If you can't meet us at one
of our POPs, what do you do?
You do cloud VPN or the
partner interconnect solution.
And we'll get into all
the details about how
all this stuff works promptly.
So the first thing
we'd like to talk about
is how you use IPsec.
IPsec is a low cost reasonable
bandwidth solution into GCP.
So roughly, depending on how
you connect to us, if you're
connecting to us
over a peering link,
you can get up to
3 gig per tunnel.
Otherwise, it's about 1.5
gig large packet per tunnel.
And if we go through
this diagram,
I want to point out
a couple of things.
First of all, if you notice
there are two VPN tunnels here,
and they're connecting
using BGP to a Cloud Router.
You don't have to use BGP,
you can use static routing,
but we recommend that
you use dynamic routing.
It's less error prone.
It's easier to manage.
But one of the things is--
you notice those BGP
sessions go to Cloud Router.
The Cloud Router is not
a traditional router.
All it is, is the
BGP control plane.
And if you went to an earlier
talk that discussed Andromeda
and the underpinnings
of our network,
you'll understand that what
the Cloud Router is doing
is taking routes and programming
to our underlying SDN fabric.
And what it does is
it programs routes
into the VMs and your
VPC, so those VMs
know how to get off
of your network.
And what they have is that they
have a default route to the VPN
gateway which is managing
encryption and forwarding
that traffic on to your
on-premise network.
What that means is that--
first of all, the Cloud
Router can support up
to 120 BGP sessions.
But it, obviously, can't support
128 VPNs going through it
because packets per second
would kind of overwhelm it.
So rather than worrying about
that we programmed these routes
directly into the
VMs, and all you
are then is limited
by the performance
of the VPN gateway and
each individual tunnel
which is about 1.5 gig.
But you can ECMP
that, and we have
customers that are doing
20 gig of IPsec traffic
between their VPC and
on-premise network.
So it's a cool, very
scalable solution.
It offers an SLA.
And it does have some
drawbacks in that it's
going over the public internet.
So you are sort of
beholding to the latencies
and jitter of a public
internet connection.
So many customers have used
this to start out with,
but eventually they move on
to our other interconnect
solutions which are dedicated
interconnect and partner
interconnect.
So dedicated interconnect, as
I said, it's a 10 gig solution.
In other words,
all the connections
to Google with
dedicated interconnect
are supported a 10
gig per connection.
We support [? lag ?]
groups of up to eight,
so up to about 80 gig.
And then the partner
interconnect solution,
which will give you
sub-rate interfaces starting
at 50 megabits through
many partners, which
I'll cover in just a second.
So let's talk a little
bit about the locations
around the dedicated
interconnect solution.
First of all, to
connect to us, you
need to meet us in one of
our colocation facilities.
And I'll put a list of
the colocation facilities
up in just a second.
You are placing a peering
router in that facility,
and you're connecting to
us using cross-connects
to our peering edge.
And I distinctly
say a peering edge,
because it's not a router.
It's just an edge.
It's a 10 gig port you plug in
and using our Espresso control
plane allows us to
package up your packets
and send them on to your VPC.
By the way, if you don't
know anything about Espresso,
there's a great
paper on Espresso
that explains how we
do peering on our edge.
Very interesting not just
from an academic standpoint
but just on how you
build SDN fabrics.
So to use dedicated
interconnect-- router
in one of our peering
locations and a cross-connect
to our peering edge.
A little bit on requirements.
So, first of all, it's 10
base LR, so just a comment.
We have had customers
that have come up
with other methods of connecting
to us, and those don't work.
We also support LA--
we require LACP.
The benefit of
LACP is as you want
to grow that infrastructure,
you can do it in a seamless way
by adding 10 gig connections
and growing that lag
bundle as you need to.
So for customers that have very
large data rate requirements
or are thinking they're going
to have very large data rate
requirements, it's really
important for LACP to be there.
Support of 802.1q VLANs, which
most if not all routers support
that.
EBGP with multihop
is also required.
And finally, IPv4
link local addresses.
So all those are
the requirements
that you need for a dedicated
interconnect solution.
As part of the process, you
go into the cloud console,
you'd get an LOA.
You hand it over
to your data center
provider, whoever
that is, and they
would make that connection.
There's a very hold-your-hand
approach on setting up
these connections.
So after you get
the LOA, there's
instructions in
the email of what
to do next and take you step
by step through the process
of setting up that connection.
So we find it,
for the most part,
to be very non-error prone, lead
you through the whole process.
And we've had very,
very few escalations
from customers having a
problem through that process.
So we try to hold your hand
if you're using this method.
As far as interconnect
locations,
this is what we have
today across the globe.
So in North America--
a couple locations
in Canada and a host
of locations throughout
the United States.
One of the comments
I will make is that--
and I don't have an overlay of
our data center fabric here--
but when you may be concerned
about latency to VM workloads,
and if you're concerned about
latency to VM workloads,
you want to be extremely
close to those VMs workloads.
So for instance, in
our Ashburn facility--
that's the one that's
marked as Washington, DC--
you're roughly around a
millisecond away from a VM.
Same thing with our
Los Angeles facility,
same thing with Frankfurt,
London, and a few others--
Tokyo and a few others
around the globe.
If you're really
concerned about latency--
for instance, if you're
doing a lift and shift
workload, where you
have to leave some of it
in your data center--
so let's say you have a very
large DB2 in-memory database
that you need to leave
in your data center.
You might want to think
about those facilities
because you can take
that infrastructure
and deploy in that facility
and still have low latency
access to your VM workloads.
So just something to think about
when you go around selecting
a location to connect to us.
One thing I will say about
this list of locations.
It's a evolving
list of locations.
So if you don't see
it up there, it's
probably going to be up there in
about another couple of months
or another half a
year, et cetera.
So we're slowly
rolling out locations
that support dedicated
interconnect over
the next year.
So there will be a number of
additional locations there.
So now let's talk a
little bit about partner.
So the big difference
between dedicated and partner
is that you're not meeting
us in one of our colocation
facilities.
We have a number of partners
that actually have connections
in our colocation facilities
and can provide you a Layer 2
connection into that location.
So that means that
you're in your facility,
and you're using one of
those partners to connect us.
There are different
kinds of partners
that can help you connect.
So let's talk a
little bit about them.
They're wave partners.
Wave partners are providing
you a physical optical cable
from your location
to a Google location.
In that use case, you're
actually using the dedicated
product, but you're using it
like if it was an extended--
the optical fiber was like
an extended cross-connect.
So you'd hand your LOA
to your wave partner,
and they would figure
out where they're
meeting us or you
tell them where
you want to meet that fiber.
And they would hand it over to
whoever's providing the patch
panel in that location.
So there are a
number of customers
that use that because
they want the bandwidth
and the connections
that dedicated offers,
but they can't meet us in one
of our colocation facility.
So they use a wave service.
The benefit of this is that you
don't have to place equipment
in the colocation facility.
Another type of partner is
what we call Layer 2 partner.
They're either by EVPN
or a pseudowire partner.
And what they're
doing is all they
provide you is a physical
connection that then you
can do a Layer 3 VLAN over
that physical connection.
So there are a
number of partners.
And if you go to our
website, we actually
characterize partners that
the Layer 2 or Layer 3
connectivity.
But those partners
are giving you
the ability to manage the VLANs
on your equipment on-premise.
And then finally there are Layer
3 partners or Layer 3 partner
MPLS VPN is a typical way
of talking about them.
They are typically doing
BGP on your behalf to us,
and then they're doing
BGP to you as well.
So they're managing how
you can connect to us.
Typically, you're connecting
with an MPLS backbone,
and you're telling them can you
please extend my MPLS backbone
to the cloud.
So for those of you that
have an MPLS partner.
This is a great way to do it.
So if you were at
a session yesterday
both AT&T with their product
called NetBond and Verizon
with their product
SCI were discussing
how to do this Layer
3 type of connection.
So what are some of
the other differences
of partner and dedicated?
I think the biggest difference
between partner and dedicated
is that you can get sub-rate
interfaces with partner.
So, for instance, if you're
a retail establishment
with many stores
all over the nation,
you don't need a 10 gig
connection per store.
You may want to sub-rate
interface per store.
You probably have
an MPLS provider.
They're giving you
100 megabit MPLS
linked to cloud for each
one of those stores.
So that's something you
can get with partner,
but you can't get with
the dedicated solution.
Some of the other
big differences--
because you're only
paying for what you need,
it can be less expensive.
It can be less
expensive with partner,
you don't have to pay for the
rack costs in a colocation
location.
You don't have to think
about the amortized cost
of the router that
you're putting
in that location, et cetera.
So sometimes partner can be a
more cost effective solution.
And as well with partner,
from start to finish--
especially, if you already
have a partner and connections
to that partner can be extremely
fast, order of minutes.
Whereas, if you're
using dedicated,
unless you have the gear placed,
you have the rack bought,
you have all of those
contracts in place
with the colocation
facility, that
can take a little bit longer.
Typically, dedicated takes
order a week versus partner
can take order minutes,
depending on the partner
connection that you have.
One other difference between
partner and dedicated
is with dedicated you
own the 10 gig circuit.
It's yours.
You can do anything
you want with it.
You [? lend ?] VLANs
in multiple projects.
And with a partner connection,
that 10 gig circuit
is shared amongst a
number of other companies.
We have provisions in place
so that that circuit is not
overloaded.
So we force our partners to
augment those circuits as they
start reaching capacity levels.
So let's talk a little bit
about the partners we have.
We launched the partner solution
about six to seven weeks ago.
And we launched it
with a set of partners.
Since then, we've added a
number of additional partners,
and we continue.
Actually, there were
a number of partners
that would have been on
this list, except they
didn't get the signature
on that contract in time.
So they were left off
the list because I had
to do my slides at some point.
So this list continues to grow.
If you don't see your
favorite partner here--
come and talk to me.
We can get them on the list.
And by the way,
if you want to see
a full list of the partners,
there's a URL for that.
In addition, at that
URL, it'll give you
additional details
about the partner,
like how do you contact
them, what services they
offer, things like that.
And I will say one thing--
with this suite of
partners, this also
extends the reach of the
number of data centers
that we support.
So if you look at
many of these partners
and you go to this URL,
you'll see that they only
meet us in certain locations.
But for instance, if you go to--
what's a good one?
If you go to our
partner like a Megaport,
they have connectivity
in a large number
of facilities across the globe.
So if you can't be in
one of our locations,
many of these
partners can help you
be in one of those locations
because they have a very
diverse set of connectivity.
An example, I just said
Megaport-- another, Equinix,
for instance, has
their own backbone
that connects all their
data centers together.
So if you're in one
of their data centers,
they can connect you to cloud.
So many of these partners
give you that last mile,
that extra data center
connectivity back into a cloud
offering like GCPs.
So let's talk a little bit about
the details of both partner
and dedicated interconnect.
I use a lot of the dedicated
interconnect diagrams here,
but they also work for the
partner interconnect solution.
So on your peering router,
whether it be on-premise
or in one of our
data center-- one
of our colocation
facilities, you're
exposing a linked local
address to the Cloud router.
We're exchanging BGP
across that link,
and we're extending your
network into cloud VPC.
That means that we take
routes from your network,
and we program those
routes on the VMs.
And we take those VMs
and expose those routes
to your data center as well.
So fully meshed-- it just looks
like you extended your data
center into another room,
but what you've done
is you've extended to the
cloud and in addition, you've
extended to the globe as I'll
go through in just a second.
So we have a
feature in the Cloud
Router called global routing.
And what global
routing does is it
takes your VPC subnets
that are in other regions
and advertise them over a BGP
connection back onto your data
center.
So if you see this diagram,
we have two connections.
One in one region and
one in another region.
Both of those connections are
advertising all the routes
that you have on your VPC.
The reason you might want
to do these in two regions
is because you may have
a connection in Tokyo
and a connection in Chicago,
but what's happening
is you're getting all
your routes to all
your VPC over those two links.
So you may have a VM running
in a data center in London,
and you still have the access
to it from your on-prem,
but you don't have a
connection in London.
And the benefit is that
you're going over our backbone
to get to those VMs.
So as I said when I
started this presentation,
you get access to that large
network with one connection.
And this is a good
example of that.
So in this use case, we're
connecting to one region
and to one Cloud Router, but
because of global routing
we're advertising the routes
to other regions over that one
link.
So in this case, let's say
you're connected in Chicago,
you still have access to
our data center in Tokyo.
You have access to our
data center in London.
You have access to our data
center in Frankfurt or Mumbai
or wherever those
regions are set up.
So it's a very
cost effective way
of extending the reach of
your data center network
to a global footprint.
Now, I will caution there are
two charges when you do this.
There is egress charges
from your local region.
So, for instance, if you're
connected in Chicago,
there'll be an egress charge
from a local region to Chicago
out.
And if you wanted
to connect to Tokyo,
you're going to pay
a Tokyo to a local US
region egress charges as well.
But again, it's
cheaper than stringing
a long, long connection
to a data center
halfway around the world.
So let's talk about how you
connect multiple projects.
In the dedicated
use case, you'd have
multiple VLANs over that
same 10 gig connection.
In the partner use case, you
just have multiple VLANs,
you don't care how they
route or who they route over.
But what you're doing now
is with multiple projects,
you have complete separation
between those two projects.
You have network to assets
in those two projects.
They don't know
one from one other,
even if you're using the
dedicated single 10 gig
connection.
They can have overlapping
address space.
They can do all
that kind of stuff.
So this is one way of
connecting multiple projects.
It is not the recommended
way, but some people
need to do it this way.
The recommended way is to use
something called shared VPC.
How many of you know
what shared VPC is?
We're doing our job.
What shared VPC
allows you to do is
think of each individual
project the way
you would think about
resources that you
have in your data center.
So when you have a developer
come to you and say,
I need VM resources,
I need network access.
I have this special
project I'm working on.
You don't care what the
project is, but you need
to give them network access--
that's what shared VPC is doing.
It lets you say I control
the network resources.
I control the firewall rules.
And I give you access based
on what your needs are.
Do you need access back to
your data center database?
Probably not, so you
firewall that stuff off.
The shared VPC allows you
to control who gets access
to the network, what
firewall rules are placed
on those individual projects.
So this is a way of using your
network assets in the most
efficient way possible.
So I have customers come to
me and say, I need 100 VLANs.
Well, why do you need 100 VLANs?
Well, I have 100 projects
I need to connect back
to my data center.
If you think about that,
what they really want to do
is they want to use shared VPC.
Because they don't
need 100 VLANs,
they want to get
networking to 100 projects.
And this is an efficient way--
actually, I got the
scaling numbers wrong.
But this is an efficient
way of giving access
to a number of projects
using one VLAN resource.
So you can put in a
high capacity VLAN
and give access to
a number of projects
and control the way they
access your data center.
And by the way, there was a
great talk on this that you
should listen to because this
[? already ?] [? happened. ?]
So it'll be available on
YouTube in a week or so.
So let's talk about
connecting to multiple clouds.
Because I don't
care who you are,
you most likely have
some resources that
are running in another cloud.
And how do you do that?
Well, there are a couple
methods of doing that.
What I'm showing here is showing
how you would use a router that
you have in a colocation
facility or on-premise,
and you'd take two legs--
stick one in one
cloud service provider
and stick the other one in GCP.
You'd get route information
from both of those,
and now you have a connection
between those resources
and to cloud infrastructures.
The one thing you
have to remember
is you are you could have an
issue with overlapping IPs,
you need to be careful
of that in that you
can't have overlapping IPs
without having a NAT device
on-premise.
Now, you say, wow,
that's a real pain.
I have to go stick a
router in some point
[INAUDIBLE] someplace and
connect this and manage
all that.
That's a real over-the-top
amount of effort.
There are companies-- and
I'll mention Megaport here
because their
product is actually
in production right now.
And there's another large
infrastructure provider
that is actually doing
something very similar.
What they've done is
they've virtualized
the routing function
in those POPs.
And they give you
APIs or user interface
that allow you to point
and click and connect
two CSPs together.
So a very easy to use,
very cloud-like approach
to connecting to cloud
service routers together.
So the Megaport solution is
called the Megaport Cloud
Router, it's on their website.
You can trial it, it has a
pretty nice user interface
to walk through.
They have a booth
on site too as well.
The other, and I can't speak
for the other company that's
doing this because
I'm not authorized to,
but I'm sure you'll
see press when they
make their solution available.
So that's how you'd
connect two cloud service
providers together.
There's actually another
method of doing this as well.
Because one thing
you can do is just
connect them using
an IPsec connection.
So the cloud VPN solution,
there are a number
of guides that help you
connect to common cloud service
provider infrastructure.
And you can make an
IPsec connection,
you can have multiple links.
You can do ECMP over
those multiple links
and get pretty
reasonable connectivity
between GCP and another
cloud service provider.
Google as a whole has
very good, I would say,
rich connectivity peering
between our CSP competitors.
So you can be assured
that those links are going
over adequate connectivity.
So let's talk a little bit
about high availability
because your connections from
your data center to the cloud
really need to have some
level of reliability
when you can connect.
So to do a--
we offer two SLA'ed levels
with the dedicated and partner
interconnect solutions.
Again, it doesn't matter
which one you're using,
you have to do more or less
exactly the same thing.
You have to meet us in
one metro with two links
to get a three nines
of availability.
What I mean by a metro is if
you remember that map with all
the points of presence,
a metro is one
of those points of presence.
So you need to meet us in one
of those points of presence
with two connections.
If you're using
dedicated, that means
you have two 10 gig links.
If you're using a
partner solution,
that means you have two VLANs
connected in that metro.
That will give you a
three nines of SLA.
We also recommend that you use
Graceful Restart on the Cloud
Router, and I'll go into some
details of that in just a bit.
To get to four nines
of availability,
you need to meet us in two
metros with two connections
in each one of those metros.
So let's say you're
meeting us in Chicago,
you also need to meet us
in Dallas or Los Angeles
or somewhere else to get the
four nines of availability.
And again, I stress that this is
two metros because our SLAs are
metro bound, and they're not
four connections anywhere
you want.
So this is a way of
getting a four nines of SLA
into the Google infrastructure.
In addition, with the
four nines of SLA,
you need to implement, global
routing on the Cloud Router
so that I can advertise all
the routes over those links.
So if one link fails, I
can use the other link
to connect to GCP.
So we talked about
IPsec as being
a method of connecting back
into the Google infrastructure
as a way to start out.
You're not sure
you want to do this
or you don't know what
the volume of connectivity
is or you're just in
a proof of concept--
so you can start with an IPsec
connection to connect to us.
The default-- by
the way, I recommend
using dynamic routing.
This particular use
case is all going
to be using dynamic routing.
And in this case, you're
advertising all your BGP routes
using a default MED of 100.
But now you want to move over
to a dedicated or partner
interconnect, so you've set up
two VLANs or two dedicated 10
gig links with VLANs over them.
And you've set a default
MED priority of 1,000.
What that means is that
your IPsec connection is
the preferred path to and
from your data center.
And the secondary path is
that dedicated interconnect.
And you can go through the
CLI or you can use the GUI,
and you can change the MED
values and traffic immediately
swings over to the preferred
method that you've chosen.
So in this use case, you've
moved all your traffic
over the VPN, and
you've moved it
on to the new dedicated
interconnect that you set up.
One of the benefits here is
also you can still maintain
that IPsec connectivity.
So if you have a problem with
the dedicated interconnect,
it'll all swing back
to your VPNs as well.
So a nice very
simple way of doing
both the transition and a
failover mechanism to the VPN
tunnels.
So we talked a little bit
about Graceful Restart as a way
to minimize downtime.
Cloud Router's a
software component,
we update it all the time.
Like, once a week, we're
doing some change to it,
updating that software.
And you will have an issue
because your BGP session
goes down.
BGP session goes down, you lose
connectivity, withdraw routes,
do all that kind of stuff.
So Graceful Restart is a way
of not withdrawing routes when
you have a BGP session down.
And it gives you the
ability to say wait
for a little bit of time
before you withdraw routes.
That BGP session might
be coming back up,
and I want to be assured that
I still have connectivity.
Our recommendation is
to-- and by the way,
there is a lot of documentation
on this on our website as well
as [? they're the ?] sample CLIs
for both Juniper and Cisco gear
on how you set all of
this up to take advantage
of our recommended
configuration.
And the recommendation is
to turn on Graceful Restart
but do not use any of the
modifiers for Graceful Restart.
And what that will do
is it will give you
a connection that has about
61 seconds of failover time.
That means if your
BGP session went down
because of an actual a physical
cut in cables or something
like that, it'll take about 61
seconds for that BPG traffic
to failover to the
secondary like.
We're going to improve
the timing on this
through implementing some
other methods that you
find in common
off-the-shelf routers.
And those of you who
know things like BFD,
and we'll improve this
failover time over time.
But this today is the default
recommended configuration,
and this will give you a
61 second failover time.
We also talked a lot
about a global routing,
and I want to go a little
bit under the covers
on how global routing
works and what
you get out of global routing.
So when you set up
global routing that means
all the subnets are advertised
over your BGP session.
If you have multiple
connections to GCP,
you want to make sure that
you're using the optimal path.
So, for instance, if you
have a connection in Tokyo
and one in Chicago, you don't
want your data center in Tokyo
to go over your backbone
and come into Chicago.
So what we do is on
the advertisement,
we modify the MEDs
of the remote subnets
by adding the RTT value
of those remote subnets.
So your subnets in Tokyo
will have a very low MED
value in Tokyo, and they'll
have a very high MED value
in Chicago.
So traffic from Tokyo will
prefer your Tokyo connections
and traffic from Chicago would
prefer the Chicago connection.
The one comment I will make
is that you should make sure
that the default MED values
are far enough apart,
so you don't run into an issue.
For instance, if you
were to default of 100,
and let's say you're doing
Chicago and New York,
you may have some interesting--
If you want to prefer your
Chicago connection all
the time, add 1,000
to the default value
that you're advertising
out of New York
so that you don't
get into an issue
where the round trip time is
longer than the default MED
value that you're advertising.
So that will always prefer
one connection over the other
if you add a very
large amount of value
to the default MED value.
And all of these
things are available
in the Cloud Router
CLI as well as
in the GUI to be able
to set all of that up.
Monitoring-- so now you have all
this great infrastructure set
up and you everything
is working great,
how do you monitor
this infrastructure?
There are two distinct ways of
monitoring this infrastructure.
One of them is you can go
into the Cloud Console,
and we will give you things
like link utilization,
drop data, et cetera.
And those are time
series values,
so you can select
whether you want
to see the last hour or the last
day or last week, et cetera.
So pretty nice,
rich user interface
around all the
monitoring data, and you
can get that right out
of the Cloud Console
in the section around the
object you're trying to monitor.
So you can go into
the interconnect
and monitor that interconnect.
With partner, you can go to
the VLAN and monitor that VLAN.
In addition to that, we also
support Stackdriver monitoring.
So, for instance, if you
want to put alerts on--
if you're using
dedicated interconnect
and you want to put alerts
on the DB value associated
with the connection--
what's the light levels on
a particular connection.
And if they drop
below a certain level
and you want to be
alerted, you can
do all of that in Stackdriver.
If you want to do an alert that
says my link utilization's up
over 75%, you can do
that into Stackdriver
and get those alerts so that
you know what's going on.
While we're talking
about alerts,
let me mention one other thing.
We take down infrastructure
from time to time--
mainly for maintenance.
We're putting a new
line card, we're
readdressing some
ports, stuff like that.
All of that information is also
available in the Cloud Console.
You can get alerts on when
we do maintenance outages.
So that you're aware--
your BGP sessions go
down, it's not an issue.
You know that's a maintenance
window, you've done an outage.
We try to notify you within
a reasonable amount of time.
So that if you want to, for
instance, swing your traffic
away from one link to another
because of that maintenance
event, you can do that.
So all of that is available
in the console, all of this
is documented as well.
So I do recommend reading
the documentation.
I'm always surprised at
how many customers always
do a Google search
before they actually
go read the documentation,
and the Google search just
takes them back to
the documentation.
So a good way to figure out
how these products work--
if there's not a lot of
documentation, there's enough.
It's not a long read
take, take advantage
of the time and effort our
Doc people go into putting out
a really stellar amount
of documentation that
helps you understand how
all this stuff works.
So finally, let's
talk a little bit
about how much all
of this stuff costs.
So VPN, we charge
$0.05 per tunnel hour.
That works out I believe $32
a month for a VPN tunnel.
With dedicated
interconnect, it's
$1,700 for a 10 gig
circuit per month.
And then for every VLAN that
you put on that 10 gig circuit,
it's a charge of $72.
If you're thinking
about redundancy,
three nines would mean two
connections, so $3,400 a month.
And then, of course, with
a four nines of redundancy,
you're doubling that
again for $6,800 a month.
On the partner interconnect,
it's a sliding scale.
It starts at about $39 a month
for a 50 megabit attachment
and goes all the way up to
$1,700 for a 10 gig attachment.
Our peering solutions are free--
both direct peering solutions
free, our carrier peering
solution is free.
Of course, you may
have to be paying
some money to whoever
the carrier is
that's helping you peer.
But we have a settlement
free peering solution.
Of course, you do pay
egress costs on those links
and those costs are [? our ?]
internet egress cost rate.
Speaking of egress
on VPN, on VPN,
it's just like an
internet connection.
So depending on how
you're connecting to us
and where you're
connecting to us,
that's runs from about $0.08 a
gig all the way to $0.23 a gig.
And the higher end
of the scale is
for places like Australia
and South America,
where it costs us a lot
more to provide transit
in those locations.
For dedicated and partner
interconnect in North America,
we charge $0.02 per gig.
If you're interested
in other locales,
please go to the website,
and all that pricing
is available there as well.
For carrier and
direct peering, we
do give a discount on
our standard internet
rate of egress, and in
North America, that's
$0.05 per gig for both
carrier and direct peering.
So we gave a lot of
sessions at this conference.
And this is the list of all
the sessions that are here.
The reason I'm putting this
up is all these sessions
will be available on YouTube.
So if you miss something that's
of crucial interest to you--
like, I think there's
actually one happening
at exactly the same time.
So if you were worrying
enterprise ready networking
for GKE, which is happening
at exactly the same time slot,
go to YouTube, and you'll be
able to get that presentation
online.
And two final
things, I don't know
if you guys have seen this.
We have a wonderful poster.
It's an online giveaway.
In other words,
you go to this site
and either you can
download it yourself
or you can have
it mailed to you.
But this is a poster
that shows our network,
all our POP locations, all
our data center locations,
all our undersea cables, all
our terrestrial cabling, et
cetera--
all in one beautiful picture.
So it's kind of cool--
put up on your wall and
people will ask you,
what's that map of
the world all about?
Finally, in closing, I'd like,
if you could, please give
feedback on this session.
You'll find feedback in the
Next '18 application under--
let's see if I get this right.
Under notifications, and
they'll have all the sessions
that you've attended.
And you can give feedback there.
It's kind of hard to
find, but we really
appreciate any
feedback you can give.
[MUSIC PLAYING]